when people find out on Vietnamese this
always happens
oh my god I love pho it's pronounced far
and yeah it's delicious but today I
wouldn't spend some time talking about
some other things that makes being
Vietnamese awesome like a sigh from afar
we have some other amazing dishes too
what do you recommend personally my
favorites are the boom bah Hawaii the
bun sale and the gum Tom also fish sauce
is the nectar of the Gods and it makes
all our food taste that much better
hmm cheer some fish sauce we're able to
speak Vietnamese when we don't want
people around us understanding us Oh
french fries and go anything on top of
the universal holidays we also have
Vietnamese holidays that's double the
festive here are you free February 16th
I can't it's New Year's nears what's the
first I know that I'm talking about that
Vietnamese New Year's you know you can
expect this to happen at the next family
gathering hey Victor oh my gosh is that
Thursday night yeah of course I do
Vietnamese people are some of the
hardest-working people I know I've seen
families do incredible things from very
little and they've taught me a lot about
courage perseverance and love and for me
the best part about being Vietnamese is
our strong sense of community and family
oh and did I mention how folklore says
Vietnamese people are descendants of a
fairy and a dragon
yeah we're magical baby
[Music]